all right so what i was talking about
here i'm not making this thing up i
guess you weren't here for this
yesterday uh the
disney which is a giant corporation uh
they've got a movie about this fouchy
guy and for some reason they sent us a
box of fouchy stuff like if you don't
think this is all just packaged [ __ ]
i've got pouchy in a box okay so this is
i guess there's a documentary it's in
conjunction with national geographic and
disney it's like you know what if there
was a freaking pandemic and they were
really fearing that everybody's dying do
you think they'd be spending any of
their money on their fancy box and let's
see what's in this ridiculous box they'd
be putting it all to figuring out how to
solve the thing oh look at this you can
get a fouchy mask that's great oh and a
little fouchy fanny pack that's nice and
fouchy cards i'm going to literally
vomit and fouchy chocolate although this
isn't branded fauchi oh and fouchy
popcorn so they want you to have
chocolate and popcorn because that way
you can become fat and die of cobin more
popcorn fouchy the book oh my god oh oh
i mean this is this is absolutely
extraordinary fouchy the [ __ ] candy
box that's what they're giving you
get me the numbers on on uh overweight
people die in a covid they fauci fauci
you got your chocolate you got your
popcorn
you got your gummy bears and your sour
patch kids and you can put it all in
your fanny pack while you're sitting
there you fat freak and then you can put
your uh your soda right here in the
fouchy
uh oh my god and what's this they're
blissey i don't even know what this is
scrunchies scrunchy
oh it's scrunchy you can put a scrunchie
in your hair too
there's no business like show business
there's no business i know
all right let's move on uh okay we got
ma here thank you for the numbers i'm
doing live fact checking right here
models estimate that uh
271 000 about 30 percent of the
hospitalizations due from covid were
attributed to obesity someone may want
to tell
fauci with his popcorn and his candy
and his chocolate
that obesity has something to do with
dying of cobalt and you know disney like
it's
it's theater you guys
it's theater